I'm a really competitive person and so
being on this list of age 24 is really
rewarding hopefully I can like you know
do something even greater and again
let's let's again before I hit 30 hi my
name is Andy Dinh I'm the CEO of TSM and
I'm 24
what TSM does is we are an eSports team
and what that means is we compete in
certain games across the globe
so we play in big stadiums like the
Staples Center or the Madison Square
Garden where we play against other teams
that are are also competing in the same
game we are for you know millions of
dollars right now we're in Counter
Strike League of Legends Smash Brothers
and Bing glory and our zone and then
we're also looking at expanding into
other tablets as well
[Music]
originally I just played a league of
Legends casually when I was I would say
17 and I mainly just played for fun and
because I was really good at that game
at that time and I was ranked 1 on the
ladders a lot of people asked me to like
create content and guides around the
game
[Music]
I've really developed I mean just
through like the last five years I've
developed a lot as a person emotionally
and I was really immature and you know
when I first started my business I I
just said things as they wore I didn't
really care about other people's
emotions I didn't really I wasn't really
able to see it from other people's
perspectives and when I got frustrated
that's something I would just say it as
it is and that's not necessarily how you
do things in life and so I think that
you know having just like multiple
mentors like sit me down and like just
teach me to grow as a person's brilliant
if you love something you're gonna
you're not gonna see it as work you're
gonna play anyways and because you love
it so much you're gonna play so much
anyways you're just better rate if you
look at anything in life the more time
you put into something the better you
are no matter how talented you are or
not
right so passion is the 100% necessary
in order to be at the top
[Music]
you